Buonasera a tutti benvenuti Mi
congratulo Innanzitutto con gli speech
precedenti con veramente belli e
interessanti Io cercherò di fare almeno
Altrettanto anche se il tema
può essere un po' pesante Allora
parleremo di dati e algoritmi e in
qualche modo cercheremo di capire in che
misura l'uso dei dati e l'uso degli
algoritmi sta influenzando la nostra
vita
su due sfere in particolare la sfera
politica è la sfera diciamo della
sicurezza della cosiddetta giustizia
predittiva
partiamo proprio da quest'ultimo punto e
partiamo da quell'immagine in alto a
sinistra
ci siamo chiesti come mai la polizia Ha
perquisito e poi ha ammazzato proprio
George Floyd e non uno di noi bianco
come in questa sala
proveremo a spiegarlo alla fine di
questo Talk e ma è abbastanza
impressionante
affiancare la storia di George Floyd
alla storia di di radio raim che uno dei
protagonisti del film Fa la cosa giusta
di Spike Lee del 1989 che racconta
esattamente la stessa storia con più di
30 anni di anticipo
mentre il tema delle elezioni politiche
lo vedremo tra un po' e ho riportato
quest'altro bellissimo film che Taxi
Driver che si interseca un po' con una
storia politica statunitense e con
questa frase abbastanza populista che
leggete a sinistra We are the people che
era lo slogan del di uno dei degli
interpreti del film una figura
secondaria ma comunque importante
nel titolo trovate scritto Deta ma in
realtà quello che hanno interessa sono i
big data è un termine di uso comune ma
in realtà esiste nei vocabolari da meno
di 10 anni tra il 2013 e il 2014 compare
nei vocabolari statunitensi e Chi
produce big data il big data Vengono
prodotti Principalmente dagli smartphone
tutti i sistemi connessi a Internet ma i
grandi produttori di dati sono
ovviamente le case farmaceutiche che
trasmettono
tutto tutto ciò che fanno Chi compra i
farmaci ai server che gestiscono queste
informazioni ma anche tutti i nostri
acquisti sui beni di consumo minimi un
pacco di biscotti viene completamente
tracciato chi immagazzina questi dati i
dati sono immagazzinati nel mondo
occidentale sostanzialmente da solo
cinque aziende cinque aziende al mondo
nel mondo occidentale non conosco
abbastanza bene la situazione cinese e
neanche quella russa ma nel mondo
occidentale Facebook Google Amazon Apple
e Microsoft Hanno praticamente tutti i
nostri dati tutti perché tutti i dati
vengono depositati sui data server di
proprietà di queste aziende
quindi possiamo dare tante definizioni
al termine big data quindi trovate
alcune interessanti su questo sito
dell'università di berkeley ma io ho
riportato questa che a me piace di più e
che leggiamo insieme Dice storicamente
molte decisioni politiche e militari
economiche e personali vengono prese dai
cervelli che operano
secondo logiche non predicibili sulla
base di esperienze soggettive big data
rappresenta un cambiamento culturale in
cui sempre più decisioni vengono prese
da algoritmi che funzionano secondo
logiche trasparenti e prevedibili quindi
il termine Big non si riferisce a quanto
è grande il nostro insieme di dati ma
alla natura pervasiva di questo
cambiamento
è una definizione più tecnica di big
data
li associa alle 4v volume quindi una
grande quantità di dati varietà dati
acquisiti da fonti eterogenee quindi
carte di credito esami del sangue
immagini catturate dalle telecamere così
via e velocità cioè questi dati si
aggiornano velocemente a mano a mano che
vengono raccolti acquisiti e memorizzati
la quarta V non l'ho segnata lì è
pleonastico è ovviamente valore questi
dati sono importanti perché hanno un
valore economico importante
ora appunto chiediamoci velocemente come
facciamo a produrre questi dati e quindi
chiediamoci quanti dispositivi connessi
a Internet a ognuno di noi immaginando i
telefonini immaginando gli iPad i
computer le Smart TV eventualmente i
navigatori tutto quello che vi viene in
mente chi ne ha soltanto uno alzi la
mano ora Facciamo un esperimento per
capire se stiamo vivendo nel passato nel
presente o nel futuro Quindi chi ha
soltanto chi non ne ha nessuno alzi la
mano
uno solo uno qualcuno ne ha solo uno chi
ne ha 5 o più di 5
Perfetto Siamo tutti nel presente
allora guardate nel 2003 c'era soltanto
un dispositivo collegato a internet ogni
10 persone quindi la seconda fila dove
ci sono 10 persone si sarebbe dovuta
dividere l'unico computer per
controllare l'email in dieci con un
computer Nel 2020 Questa è una media
mondiale ci sono 6 dispositivi e mezzo
per ogni persona e vedete come se ogni
dispositivo collegato a internet nel
2003 si fosse riprodotto avesse fatto
figli e nipoti figli di nipoti eccetera
per un fattore 8000 quindi in 17 anni i
dispositivi connessi a Internet Si sono
riprodotti molto di più degli umani gli
umani sono passati da 6 miliardi a 7
miliardi i dispositivi connessi a
Internet da 500 milioni a 50 miliardi
E ogni anno noi
produciamo il 40% dei dati in più
dell'anno precedente quando entrano
questi quando entra L'analisi dei dati
nella competizione politica entra
prepotentemente nella campagna di Obama
qui Vi ho riportato l'annuncio del
professore
ragidani che fonda intorno al 2010 una
startup per fare analisi di dati per
competizioni politiche che diventa il
capo dello staff di Obama e questo è
l'annuncio che lui mette su LinkedIn
siamo in cerca di esperti data Scientist
che vogliono fare la differenza la
campagna di Obama vedrà un ampliamento
del team analitico per risolvere
problemi di data mining su vasta scala e
forte impatto si presentano diverse
opportunità di inserimento professionale
a tutti i livelli di esperienza
cerchiamo di esperti di statistica di
apprendimento automatico di analisi del
testo di analisi predittiva per lavorare
su grandi volumi di dati e contribuire
ad orientare la strategia elettorale
questo non annuncio che era presente su
LinkedIn ci rendiamo conto di tutto
questo qualche anno dopo con lo scandalo
Cambridge analytica con lo scandalo
Cambridge analytica Noi capiamo il
valore dei dati personali soprattutto
Nelle competizioni politiche
ora i dati sono carburante ma il
carburante senza un motore non serve a
nulla Così come un motore senza
carburante non può funzionare E chi è il
motore che si alimenta dei Big data
l'intelligenza artificiale
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale
sono importanti Sì sono importanti chi
svilupperà la migliore intelligenza
artificiale diventerà il padrone del
mondo Questa è un pensiero
espresso nel 2017 Qualcuno sa da chi
Vladimir Putin Questa è una frase di
Vladimir Putin
ma tutto Il decennio è un decennio
contrassegnato dalla comprensione
dell'importanza dei dati in tutti gli
ambiti della società quindi
riportiamo WikiLeaks
e quindi diciamo il lavoro fatto da
sange
informatico e giornalista australiano
per pescare nei siti governativi notizie
che non si volevano diffondere e ancora
prima nel 2014 il famosissimo scandalo
della sorveglianza di massa quando si
scoprì che la National Security agency
sostanzialmente ascoltava le telefonate
di tutti i cittadini americani senza
ragione quindi non i sospettati di
qualcosa Le ascoltava e basta
e quindi c'è questa vignetta che a me fa
sempre molto ridere in cui Obama fa
visita in una scuola e un bambino gli
dice
Ho saputo da papà che voi ci spiate e
lui spiega il bambino quello non è tuo
padre
ora
passiamo ai nostri casi di studio tre
casi di studio Il primo è eclatante si
chiama il megafono dell'ettore il
megafono del lettore è un esperimento
che ha fatto Facebook ha insaputo ha
insaputa di tutti in particolare ha
insaputa dei cittadini statunitensi
perché è stato fatto su di loro
è sostanzialmente Che cosa è consistito
è consentito in questo il giorno delle
elezioni
2 novembre 2010 i 61 milioni di utenti
Facebook che erano iscritti alle liste
elettorali e che si sono Collegati a
Facebook potevano sperimentare tre
situazioni diverse la prima situazione
su 600 mila persone non succedeva nulla
la seconda situazione gli compariva
quella cosa in alto dove c'era scritto
hanno votato tot persone tu puoi andare
a votare là e se hai già votato mi puoi
premere il pulsante così Il contatore va
avanti e poi invece su 60 milioni di
persone un esperimento fatto
all'insaputa di 60 milioni di persone
questo è stato pubblicato su Nature
quindi non me lo sto inventando l'ho
letto da loro è un articolo pubblicato
da fecio da Facebook su nature's su 60
milioni di persone che cosa che
sperimentano fatto hanno detto puoi
andare a votare là hanno votato otto
persone ti avviso che questi sei tuoi
amici hanno già votato
quei sei volti sono volti di amici
graduati a seconda del grado di amicizia
e per fare questo loro hanno lavorato
due anni prima incrociando i dati Social
con i dati reali per cui poteva capitare
per esempio che a me comparivano i sei
amici del cuore mentre a un'altra
persona gli comparivano sei amici meno
amici sono andati a misurare Se per caso
questa popolazione era andata a votare
più delle altre e all'interno di questa
popolazione se quelli che avevano avuto
il messaggio dagli amici del cuore
Ovviamente gli amici del cuore non
sapevano di mandarli questo messaggio
avevano votato più degli altri e hanno
scoperto di sì hanno scoperto dissi per
un effetto non enorme Ma assolutamente
misurabile questa cosa è importante
questa cosa importante perché è
importante perché per i collegi
uninominali basta un voto per prendere
il collegio e ricordiamo tutti bene che
nella campagna che fece Bush presidente
lui prese lo stato della Florida per 537
voti in più dell'avversario che era Al
Gore che lo
0,01%, quindi un Epsilon
e prendendo la Florida diventò
presidente degli Stati Uniti
primo tema gli online Social Network
possono fare andare le persone a votare
di più o di meno ovviamente non è
difficile immaginare che possano fare
andare a votare chi vogliono loro perché
magari possono mandare messaggi soltanto
una parte politica tu mi dai il tempo o
no posso andare
sono a 12 minuti Grazie
seconda
seconda questione dopo un po' di anni
mi è comparso quest'altro studio molto
interessante fatto da questo gruppo
dell'università di Oxford
che si occupa di questa cosa che si
chiama computational propaganda cioè la
propaganda fatta attraverso i computer
qui vado velocissimo che cosa hanno
scoperto hanno scoperto che nella
settimana durante le lezioni di Trump
55 mila account falsi di Twitter Cioè
non riconducibili a persone vere hanno
inondato i cittadini americani con 126
milioni di messaggi tutto questo
avveniva da server Russi non ho detto
della nazione Russia ho detto server
collocati in Russia
facendo analisi complicatissime sempre
basate su intelligenza artificiale
quindi qui un intelligenza artificiale
che combatte il male
che cosa si è trovato si è trovato che
attraverso Twitter e Facebook il gruppo
di supporter di Trump ha diffuso una
quantità di notizie false superiore a
quella di tutti gli altri gruppi messi
insieme sia su Twitter che su Facebook
Queste sono delle mappe di aggregazioni
di gruppi che
leggono e scrivono notizie false e
diciamo questo studio di Oxford che è
uno studio davvero particolarmente
interessante ha trovato questo risultato
che diciamo ha un che è di interessante
ancora di più
quindi secondo tema computational
propaganda esiste
è esistita
e probabilmente esiste ancora
arriviamo alla domanda con cui ho aperto
Come mai è stato perquisito George Floyd
Nel 2020 A Minneapolis Come mai è stato
ucciso George Floyd a Minneapolis
Allora le forze di polizia ovviamente
non sono infinite non possono
pattugliare tutto acqua 24 continuamente
devono fare delle scelte ormai
utilizzano motori di intelligenza
artificiale per fare queste scelte
quindi questo che voi Vedete è un
software che si chiama Brad Poll se
controllate sul telefonino Andate sul
sito e trovate il software volendo lo
potete anche comprare e questo software
praticamente Che cosa fa c'è scritto qui
noi facciamo delle predizioni basate
sulle informazioni che le vittime hanno
fornito alla polizia e lo vogliamo fare
per ridurre
le vittime e rendere le società più
sicure questo software è stato
sviluppato da università pubblica Iussi
e lei anche l'esperimento di Facebook
era stato fatto con un'università
pubblica californiana
e quindi quando le forze di polizia
escono per il pattugliamento Che cosa
fanno aprono questa specie di iPad e
l'iPad gli dice
gli mostra questi quadrati Rossi
quindi lì dice dove andare anche quando
andare
Allora la domanda è questo software è
neutrale non è neutrale
Guardate qui nel 2011
il 4 per il 5% della popolazione di New
York tra i 14 e 24 anni e black o latino
ma vengono perquisiti nel 41% dei casi
del totale quindi un fattore 10 rispetto
alla loro rappresentatività
nella popolazione
e quindi è scoppiato dieci anni fa circa
questo scandalo su questo software e
quindi diciamo possiamo dire con
certezza che questo software è razzista
in maniera inequivocabile
che cosa dice il software dice cosa dove
e quando
E che cosa fanno le forze di polizia
quando fermano i cittadini americani
usano sempre la stessa tecnica che si
chiama
ferma chiedi e perquisisci
Quindi le persone vengono fermate e
vengono perquisite
il modo di funzionare di questo
algoritmo è basato su teorie
sociologiche non è un problema tecnico
l'addestramento dell'algoritmo
l'addestramento dell'algoritmo Dipende
da cosa gli si dice di fare e
l'algoritmo viene addestrato per
aumentare la possibilità di successo
cioè
fermare sempre persone che hanno
potenzialmente commesso crimini e
perquisirle Qualunque sia il tipo di
crimine e Qualunque sia il tipo di
crimine deriva da
lo statement di tolleranza zero di
Rudolf Giuliani a New York ed era teoria
delle finestre rotte che ancora
precedente che non approfondisco per
ragioni di tempo ma che potete
tranquillamente trovare su internet
quindi quello che noi ci dovremmo
chiedere anche qui noi cittadini Bianchi
saremmo disposti a sopportare
l'oltraggio di essere perquisiti il 10%
di volte in più
di un'altra etnia presente nella nostra
nazione la risposta è scontata
concludo
Le multinazionali dell'internet
dell'information in Communication
Technology sono soggetti politici
Evidentemente sì lo abbiamo dimostrato
poi anche nel corso degli anni tutti
quanti voi ricordate
l'audizione di Zuckerberg al parlamento
statunitense le opportunità offerte dai
big data in questo momento si
armonizzano con le regole della
democrazia anche anche su questo
possiamo essere abbastanza certi della
risposta la risposta è no siamo in un
momento che chiamiamo big data
Revolution e come tutti i momenti come
tutte le fasi di rivoluzione siamo fuori
dall'equilibrio Quindi in questo momento
sicuramente c'è una fortissima
sproporzione tra quello che possiamo
fare con i big data e quello che è
giusto fare
e soprattutto siamo lontani dall'idea
del dato come bene pubblico
produciamo dati sostanzialmente come
consumatori la percentuale di quello che
facciamo con i dati come servizi a noi è
molto più bassa di quello che facciamo
come acquirenti di qualche tipo di merce
quindi concludo riportando questa
bellissima frase che direi sembra quasi
una presa in giro di Facebook
nell'articolo del megafono del lettore
loro si chiedono se vogliamo veramente
capire e migliorare la nostra società il
benessere e il mondo intorno a noi è
importante
capire se l'uso di questi metodi cioè
quelli di propaganda elettorale
possono influenzare il comportamento
reale delle persone e la risposta che si
sono dati è che tutti noi ci diamo E sì
è evidente quindi che siamo in una
situazione di Tale e disparità per cui
tra il forte il debole e la libertà che
opprime è la legge che libera
vi saluto vi ringrazio e vi consiglio
questi quattro libri che purtroppo non
ho scritto io ma che hanno mi hanno
fortemente ispirato per questo Talk
Grazie ancora
[Applauso]